What's up everybody?
Daemon Hatfield here with IGN News.
In the highly publicized Apple versus Samsung case,...
... the jury has ruled largely in favor of Apple,...
...finding Samsung guilty of willfully infringing Apple patents.
The jury arrived at the decision after a very short deliberation.
More than a few wild developments surfaced during the case,...
including a 130-page document that Samsung used...
...to compare their phones to the iPhone...
...and a judge asking an Apple attorney if he was on crack.
The court claims that Samsung slavishly copied the iPhone.
The jury has ruled that many Samsung devices from the S2...
...to the Infuse 4G were infringing on Apple's patents,...
...patents which Apple argued added perceived value to its phones.
Samsung will owe Apple more than one billion in damages.
You heard that right: one billion dollars.
An appeal is all but inevitable.
On September 20th, there will be a ruling on injunctions...
which will determine if and which Samsung phones...
...will need to be pulled from the market.
This isn't the first time that Samsung has been found infringing on patents.
In 2009, in the major case versus Sharp,...
...Samsung was banned from selling and advertising...
...a wide variety of its LCD devices.
No word yet on whether or not that Apple attorney was actually on crack.
As soon as I have confirmation either way, I'll let you know right here at IGN.